l'épisode de cette semaine est présenté
encore une fois vous l'aurez deviné par
pauli slip on clôt l'année 2020 avec
polisse l'ipag notre partenariat qui
dure depuis si longtemps pour laisser
vous les connaissez on en parle
pratiquement tous les podcasts c'est une
compagnie québécoise qui fait des
matelas et des oreillers de grande
qualité
il y en a pour vraiment tous les goûts
tous les budgets tous les besoins
là on est en on est on approche de noël
si vous entendez ce soit noël ou une
elle s'en vient si vous avez des cadeaux
de dernière minute à faire des oreillers
c'est tout le temps bon depuis - voulant
de parler honte on dort sur des
oreillers par les slips
ils peuvent être plus large plus minces
ils peuvent correspondre à vos besoins
de sommeil est favorisée vous l'aurez
deviné votre sommeil
donc on a un code promo encore une fois
qui aidé sans filtre s25 pour 25 % de
rabais sur tous exceptés les sommiers
donc dirigez vous vers pas les slips si
vous écoutez le son filtre podcast
j'espère vraiment que rendus à cette
étape ci lorsque vous allez avoir besoin
d'un nouveau mât club c'est probablement
même maintenant parce qu'on chante le
matelot vraiment trop peu fréquemment
j'espère que vous allez penser à police
l'a fait qu'encore une fois merci pour
les slips pour la belle collaboration de
2020 puis on espère travailler avec vous
en 2021 fait sur ce bonne écoute
salut gagne cph du studio sfr vous savez
ici au studio on enregistre nos podcasts
mais on loue aussi l'espace pour plein
monde qui veulent enregistrer le leur
c'est un service clé en main qu'on offre
ça vient avec l'équipement ça vient avec
l'audio avec les vidéos ça viendra avec
nicole qui travaillent ici qui va
pouvoir vous aider à cheminer dans votre
projet de podcasts donc si vous avez un
nouveau projet que vous voulez lancer si
vous avez un projet que vous voulez a
mené à un autre niveau
le studio sf c'est vraiment l'endroit où
est ce que vous pouvez venir faire ce
sens vous tracasser puis si vous me
croyez pas m'avait coûté quelqu'un qui
loue le studio donc
entendez le de la boj notamment levac
qui en aime le podcast de thomas levac à
l'eau je crois en un moment pour
remercier d'hommes et ph pour le studio
sans filtre c'est un incroyable
environnement pourtour enregistré
tournée des podcasts ce qui est génial
ou son filtre le studio est beau une
belle ambiance et toute la technique est
prise en charge par th d'un nikola
alors tout ce que j'ai à faire c'est me
présenter dire des niaiseries
je prends le métro j'arrive chez moi et
mon podcast est dans mon ordinateur
c'est incroyable comme service j'adore
et je me sens totalement libre je sais
que les gars écoute mais podcast ayant 2
0 ce que je dis il me laisse quand même
la liberté de faire ce que je veux comme
je veux
ils merci si je gagne ma vie grâce aux
podcasts c'est en grande partie grâce à
deux mais ph alors merci beaucoup
grâce à vous je peux obligé d'aller
travailler ce bruit et de me faire
croire que jeune artiste sandwich
merci beaucoup une production du studio
sfr bienvenue à s'infiltrer les pas de
casque on parle de ce qu'on veut avec
nos invités dati chbm quentin avec moi
des plantes tentation est souveraine
nous encourager les gangs
allez vous abonner à notre pétrole on
est actif notre pécule quand même
approche est podcast enfin après encore
moins de filtres en fait ça s'appelle ou
est-ce qu'on jam sur le podcast ont-ils
trois pièces par mois vous avez accès à
tout ça et vous avez aussi accès à tous
les podcasts on enregistre avant tout le
monde
aucune raison pour ait aucune raison de
parler sur sur pétrone cette semaine ban
xt oui on a aussi une assise ce que
j'aime vraiment vraiment beaucoup que la
cible de quelques mots son troisième
album notre dame des sept douleurs
s'appelle klô pelgag vous l'avez vu dans
le titre si vous avez cliqué
c'était super le fun on a parlé de
vraiment pas la face au processus
créatif en studio comment ça fonctionne
convaincre les cris les toons puis on
est allé dans pleins pleins d'avenue que
vous découvrirez dans l'épisode qui suit
on rit beaucoup on a eu du fun en a
parlé de musique qu'on a parlé de jets
pas laisser mon obsession pour bob dylan
qui a duré 30 secondes jeudi dans
l'intro non plus qui c'était moi c'est
j'étais vraiment content c'était
quelqu'un qui était sur ma liste
personnelle de personnes que je voulais
rencontrer avec les podcasts et c'est
maintenant fait chic
est-ce que tu qualifierait claude
eugénie musique en moi je pense que si
une définition trop mal ça frôle safran
le génie - non mais vraiment vraiment
talentueuse s'il ne connaissait pas sa
musique si jamais vous êtes ici mais
vous la connaissez pas à l'écouté ce c3
d'albums sont magnifiques
alors je recommande fortement puis là
derrière font la fête on l'a fait en
caoutchouc action on nous dit que c'est
ce qu'il faut faire dans les médias
sociaux fait que et commentés commenté
guette c'est koné brancher une caméra
autres on est connecté au lit et j'ai
croqué la dernière alors que je commence
à me sentir un peu comme la laine la
directrice de radio en force et la lazio
les jeunes you légende grâce à me sentir
un peu iodée
ouais en tout cas je tourne dans ma tête
et que tu es commenté like et les
symptômes rappelé henri thing sur balles
à dos sur spotify les kits puis bon
podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
t'as jamais fait d'un pro on choisit un
sujet pendant qu'on l'avait fait avec
ludivine le dessus sur le toit afin non
champions on parle de champagnac toutes
les musiques non acquis parlons de
musique se font qu'on a fait ce soir
dix mois qu'il entend karmapa qui fait
qu'on va pas parler d'un procès fusée
mais on reste à parler de musique par
exemple fait toute la musique
comment ça se passe ta vie en
confinement de lucioles mais c'est ça ça
va bien mais c'est quand même des peines
dans ces comme d'accepter chaque étape
une l'une après l'autre mais le timing
était défavorable at on est grand
maintenant
ouais je sais pas je trouve pas ça si
dramatique que ce qu'ils jugent comme
mettons personnellement j'aurais envie
d'en faire le spectacle j'ai pas envie
d'en faire dix mille je m'en faire comme
plein mais j'aime à sceaux où moi enfin
c'est ce même et sinon tu es comme moi
j'ai un jeune enfant
ouais ça donc je trouve ça te cueillette
mais c'était on a su bien mélanger n'a
que deux semaines pythie lui c'était
comme ben moi dans mon cycle des
créations c'est comme ça adonne parfait
le site et comme j mise en page je
rentrais en création faut que ça change
rien à ma vie c'est à d'autres que c'est
comme chantal bonne patate en même temps
face mettrons tout un album il était
prêt depuis un but par un simple soutien
qui est arrivé
il est prêt depuis
saillard n'en était comme prêts à y
aurait six souffrent comme est ainsi son
décolleté fois king fiara mais ce n'est
pas le montrer à personne malade à torse
en même temps si je comprends un titre
avec des producteurs bien les braults
puis lyon qui sait ils veulent juste que
ça se passe bien et non qui place les
trucs qui font comme on veut on va
attendre pour que tout soit comme qu'on
est un bon plan et tout le monde avait
un plan pour rester quand même la sorte
si la mieux préparée de tout ce que j'ai
jamais connu au pied qui le barça se
passer différemment la danse ou comme
l'album est sorti partout dans le monde
en même temps que j'avais comme et
période de promo en europe par exemple i
télé tourner là-bas et toupie une
tournée au japon aussi ben t'es ça se
passe peuvent donc en même temps j'ai
quand même raison que l'album rejoint
des gens tout de même si un recycleur
les gens ont eu le temps de l'écouter
ligne en toi exact les gens ont le temps
de consommer de l'hôtel ont besoin que
je pense mais où débutait sa santé en
avril
je t'ai dit qu'on va rapporter pas été
fait acquis facof le folfori mais en
fait c'est l'équipe qui ont fait bien et
on va t'il le tout est que tout était
paralysé l'enam en harcelant c'était
comme jamais rien exporte y avait rien
si on pouvait même pas les 10 qui était
pas prêt voyez toutes été la chaîne
s'était arrêté on avait tout envoyer
mais c'est resté
personne ne pouvait entrer dans les
trucs qui impulse dans l'esprit quand
même cool dedans dans ce sens le jeu
tout comme le sentiment de partout dans
le monde pandémie mondiale tout est
arrêté comme piloter y avait des gens ne
fait que news comme loulou redevient
bleus
dauphin rentrer à venise ouais enfin le
capitalisme s'arrêter c'est vrai qu'il
ya quand même quelque chose tu es t on
on dit on se plaint que tellement votre
ouverture occuper mon époque sud ce qui
est d'avoir une pause forcée de mon
petit temps comme ça pas mal d'arrêter
tant que ce parce que t'as pas le choix
puis tout le monde est arrêté en plus
fait que non plus l'impression que tout
est chiffré à gauche et à droite
ça m'a fait chier mais ça m'a fait bien
même tenter maintenant sur d'autres
aspects c'était c'est un moment
historique m'en sépare intéressant dans
lequel je pense que tout mais aussi
l'espoir qu'il ya des gros changements
ok ça c'est aussi con con et des
constats immense par rapport à plein de
choses
malheureusement je pose certaines
questions j'ai le feeling que toute
cette espèce de petit qu'un conte et on
a un premier confinement là on sentait
vraiment une effervescence de comme la
communauté qui tout le monde ensemble
dans le même bateau puis on prendra
aussi la peau fait qu tille 2 avec son
passé premièrement la communauté s'est
vite revirer de bord en faisant en
commençant à se pointer du doigt puis à
kirk questionner toutes les décisions
ont été prises le tir est classé par la
communauté devenue rapidement séparation
à l'encore plus grande qu'il espèce de
confort de se dire ok la vie était
freinée tout va trop vite on est anxieux
pendant deux semaines ça qu'à marquer un
break forcé pour tout le monde parce que
c'est devenu de l'anxiété est encore
pire avec cette espèce d'effervescence
le salut est arrêté rapidement j'ai
l'impression mais on est conditionné le
performant que ma à courir le sait aussi
je pense ici de se battre contre des
années 2
brainwash de juste comme il faut qu'ils
trouvent qu'est ce que tu veux faire
dans la vie après on va à l'école mais
il faut que tu aies des loisirs qui
t'apporte quelque chose qui te qui te
font grandir comme un être humain un
pilote il ya de quoi c'est surtout la
semaine ses toiles à ton arme et on est
dessus ou encore ali qui un peu
carriériste ou mais ça dépendrait pas
sexy de dire oui au mot carriériste même
un carriériste
je pense que oui un peu dans le sens où
que j'ai quand même des ambitions mais
c'est pas les ambitieuses et un plus
beau mot que vraiment mais c'est sûr que
moi j'ai des options alors mais c'est
pas nécessairement mon ambition c'est
pas d'être comme partout bon pigeon
d'être connu fini s'est pas là ma partie
préférée le met en action c'est plus que
met-on avancer dans ce que je fais puis
puis évolué dans la forme d'or que
j'exerce ou que j'essaie d'exercer en
tout cas puisque donc mes pensées sont
beaucoup diriger vers ce depuis toujours
qui est depuis toujours
volodko unlock qui arrivait de dire est
ce que au début c'était un petit peu
aussi de l'idée d'être capable de vivre
de sortie il est quand même l'enjeu
monétaire qui au delà de vouloir
s'améliorer puis grandir en tant
qu'artiste j'ai quand même manger
moniteurs qui te permettre de grandir en
tant qu'artiste ouais mais rapidement
j'ai quand même réussi à en vie ouais
puis oui c'est sûr que l'enjeu monétaire
passé comme un métier qui s'était le
moindrement anxieux c'est sûr que tu es
saporta ça commente la vision du futur
le pij or comment tu t'es tu évolues
commente arriva comme garder être
pertinent à toutes les époques de ta
propre vie
je sais pas si le doute sur sa création
le trio se mettant dans la création il
ya des phases de tout peut partir du
moment où ricco est la plus belle chose
que jamais fait pis le lendemain tu dis
je trouve sa chipie le choc passé en ses
dosettes le souvent mais
exactement mais tu sais moi j'ai tout le
temps je toujours dans le doute quand
même mais j'étais j'essaie de travailler
là bas comme pur style est toujours
maître c'est quand même je pense que
c'est que le doute c'est difficile à
gérer aussi parce que ça fait partie de
la création comme si un moteur inégal à
jeumont de de douter de soi même de
vouloir se surpasser de surprendre pi2
pas s'asseoir le d'être confortable puis
en même temps des fois c'est juste quand
tu perds le contrôle de ce même la perte
de contrôle s'est c'est bien mais si
mauvaise comme je pense que les
meilleures choses arrive quand tu parles
contrôle lorsque justement t il pas en
train de trop intellectualiser ce que tu
fais ça c'est la plus belle partie de la
création
d'après moi mais perdent le contrôle de
ses émotions comme étant dans une vie
dans la vie de tous les jours c'est la
meilleure des ondes
non donc voila tout était un peu à
double tranchant donc le doute c'est
aussi c'est c'est intéressant mais était
des fois je pense qu'ils ont réfléchi
beaucoup trop lasser comme je sens
maintenant ici comme témoigne de
l'époque dense mais s'il cédait 2,3 être
surexposé
mais je pense pas que je le suis pas
pour ces hommes est en moi je me si je
fais trop de trucs en même temps le
médiatique trucs comme je me gausse je
faisais pas aux tricheurs en automne non
parce que là bas comme ça j'en parlais
dernièrement à mettre quelqu'un était
comme on est tellement pas habitué de
voir des du monde
mal à l'aise monde off ou calmont normal
d'enfants qui réfléchissent en temps
réel m me pose une question fait comme
le laisse pas c'est oui si tu devrais
faire des pauses aussi longue que tu
vois ce qu'on fait en trente secondes de
silence en fait trente secondes de
silence radiophonique les 30 ans de la
ventilation ou pas eu l'impression
qu'ils fallaient qui participent à ce
jeu-là moins que beaucoup de monde la
musique et j'essaie de la porte et puis
de faire des trucs pour pour ça et vers
le monde puisse aider fois je fais des
trucs plus grand public que je sais pas
s'il me dit qu'il faut de la diversité
dans l'espace médiatique comme témoin
sur l'adolescente pilote mes parents
regardent la télévision puis joue à tous
dans la même affaire je me reconnais
dans rien je trouve ça plate la vie
utile
comme c'est le fun de voir quelqu'un qui
est un petit peu tout croche à la télé
puis le fait quand même
ok c'est un peu drôle c'est comme étant
jean leloup ça fait du bien quand il
était chez moi j'ai toujours adoré ces
entrevues
parce que oui il est souvent présenté
comme un peu fou mais pour moi il peu
fou je pense qu'elle sculpte à gérer
peut-être mais ces groupes tout évident
oui sauf que il ya des réflexions
beaucoup plus pertinente que 99% des
trucs que je regarde quand un artiste ou
vedettes vous à la télévision qui parle
du jeu
de qui parle juste de commencer mais
toutes les entrevues de jean leloup ses
déchets c'est tout le temps des jets de
winnipeg qui comme ça pour être scripté
c'est incroyable t il ya un esprit divo
jamais répondre à la question d'un
bonheur que tu t'attends la manière qui
est quelqu'un de hongrie mais normal
vous répondez vous trouvez une twister
va partir sur autre chose sur ce mal en
face des idées aussi là dedans qui est
comme les grands moments de vérité c'est
sur le basket parce qu'ils paient ils
pourront contrôler justement qui se sait
bull c'est la pureté de ses peaux comme
quelqu'un qui entraîné à performer pia
qui ont dissipé les questions qu'on
allait lui poser puis consciente de tout
je trouve que dans le cas de jean leloup
je trouve que le forme justement le
format qu'on parle de 80 au kaki radio
qui est rationnel fonctionne vraiment
pas pour lui au sens où met-on et je
pensais je pense juste à tout le monde
en parle d'internet au monde à part qui
racontait l'histoire où est-ce qu'ils
attachent une maison pic y était il y
avait il y avait chipé son hypothèque
que là mais je souhaite fort que je sais
pas ce que je veux c'est que tout vendu
puis talent et vivent une montagne les
fontes et puis le temps comme tout le
monde autour qui prennent soin comme une
anecdote comique tic qui font genre
énoncé bonnes histoires drôles tillon
punch et de l'humour c'est drôle mais
comme derrière tout ceci c'est pas si
drôle qui se tissent et comme c'est une
réflexion vraiment plus lointaines sur
quelqu'un qui fondamentalement et 7
vivre dans une bulle con con l'imposent
mais qui décide de le rejeter et essai
comme prétend que c'est sûr
intellectualiser l'histoire comme tel
mais je trouve que le traitement de
juste prendre ça comme une anecdote
drôle puis la cause du soudan
jean les lensois jean leloup fait que
vous nous racontez les avoir convertis
je trouve que je trouve qu'ils étaient
dans un concept dans un contexte comme
un paquet comme sur une conversation moi
je sais ce qu en rêve le teaser se
venger ou des justes à huawei de senti
qu'il était prisonnier n'a dans la
maison avec ton hypothèque tu sais quoi
là
le sentiment que tu as eue puis
qu'est-ce qui a fait que tu as pris le
choix de pulls partie fixe et quand
petite espèce de tout les gens qui qui
qui vont pas comme tu disais déjà un
petit peu champ gauche un petit peu of
de ce qu'on s'attend à voir tous et
toutes des cd des choses qui on aimerait
ça aller plus en profondeur mais les
formats traditionnels nous permettent
pas de le suivre dans son train de
penser aussi plutôt que d'essayer de le
ramener dans ta liste des questions
qu'ils avaient préparées et puis je
trouve en sus ce genre d'entrevue le
caecum jemmali question quand pose une
pipe à m me répond je t'écoute moyen de
te poser le déposer d'après tout aspect
une conversation nautisme pouces tandis
que justement de l'avoir ici voir le
suivent tant pis des bombes artisanales
à son voyage plutôt que de faire non
rivières est normal et on va les inviter
mais moi sur ce beau juste aussi que
met-on soucy passé à télévision de
matelots c'est quand même une idée
ceux qui comme l'ex pôle seul à sentir
emprisonné par d'aider les murs et les
murs et toits quand on grandit on
devient adulte sur six comme phoques par
les impôts regard des travailleurs
autonomes montagne insurmontable évident
le fonds est obligé de faire ce puits t
après c'est celui par les tirs et a
lancé il ya entendu des fallait faire ça
avec l'allemagne il ya comme un instant
deux de plus que les gens me m je vais
quand même essayer d'entrer dans le truc
qui était pas dit c'est le droit aussi
de faire ce puits le droit de peut
adhérer à tout ce que le droit aussi de
ne pas prévoir ton avenir
c'est vraiment peu comme quelque chose
de le suggérer gens qu'on nous suggère
or mais on l'oubli ça enlève un poids de
faire comme c'est vrai je suis obligé de
très beaux ni projet de travailler pour
ma retraite dgac
comme ceux justement ça me fait penser
si le poème l'albatros le baudelaire je
veux c'est une classe un gros c'est
comme l'albatros yebo qu'un qui vole qui
a ses grandes ailes piquant qui marche
sur le seul hic homme maladroit pippa
beauté pis il se fait piquer par des
matelots moi c'est ça c'est dit ce genre
d'artiste la séquence qui fait son offre
tiens quelqu'un qui attend qui dans sa
création sont 9 bis gens qui brille
vraiment aussi se poser à m on vole il
comme la batteuse qui volent c'est comme
si la plus belle chose mais justement ce
genre de truc concret terre à terre de
la vie c'est comme ça et ça fait peau
neuve
comme l'école site off le quand tu fais
de paul à toute vitesse avec un nom je
pense pas non non comment commencer
comment ça s'est passé
mettant avec un continent on parle de
jean leloup mais est ce que est ce que
la situation tu l'as tu la sainteté est
ce que tu sens que dans justement ces
affreuses
est ce que tu sens que tu es vraiment
plus toi quand tu fais ton alors que
quand tu fais des impôts mais tombe mal
à rencontrer la personne qui comme moi
les montagnes situées des impôts mieux
l'image pour représenter la vie
quotidienne 28e mais oui c'est sûr que
si rien comme ceux comme j'aimerais
qu'il y ait plus de deux cores d'impôt
de coeur de métier de d'endroits dans la
vie ou aux gars sans ce genre de truc le
comme c'est c'est quand même un espace
qui comme hors de de tous les autres
le moment petit crétin de way de mozart
ressentir ce feeling le plus souvent
dans ta vie mais ton ailleurs ouais
ouais mais oui c'est sûr je me sens
beaucoup plus mettons je sens que j'ai
plus une raison d'être
cambrai ce que quand je fais n'importe
quoi d'autre ok se nourrir que ce n'est
que ça nourrir agréable mais je sais pas
des fois je trouve qu'il ya rice a pas
de sens quand j'ai de la difficulté des
fois à trouver le sens que c'est quand
j'ai des demandes par exemple je perds
mais comment observer
mais comment comment les gens font pour
être
heureux comme tout seul qui est comme on
dirait que c'est juste des choses qui se
répètent puis kiki c'est comme une
boucle et il ya toutes les époques c'est
comme la même chose qui revient pis faut
réapprendre la prochaine génération
c'est que ma ne pas être c'est par
exemple à respecter les femmes à et le
réalisme ça existe
le respect que ça existe c'est comme
tout joueur fort c'est quand même
quelque chose
pile on essaie d'instaurer comme un
système qui ferait que quand tu arrives
paru dans le sperme c'est bien sûr tu
apprends tout ce que c'est comme un
système qui fonctionne depuis qui prend
quitté duc la bonne façon mais c'est pas
ceux qui supportent pi est ce que c'est
atteignable comme objectif de d'arriver
à créer un système qui qui nous forge
dans les temps tu veux pas que tout le
monde soit pareil non plus je pense je
pense que c'est en partie quelque chose
dans nature humaine qui fait que si
mettons dans une classe et 9 intro qui
se ressemblent plus puis une personne
qui ressent moins mais ton physiquement
l'enfant instinctivement yvon t'es foutu
disent non c'est une peau du doigt petit
fait pas ce qu'il faut comme réapprendre
tout le temps c'est drôle parce qu'en
même temps ça pourrait être aussi comme
ça y est différent mais c'est tout comme
soit c'est cool quand j'étais enfant
quand même les gens différents
simplement c'est la création social qui
fait que la réaction c'est pas cool mais
ces intrigues et puis l'intrigué devient
rapidement et connoté négativement par
ton entourage ses parts c'est un peu un
enfant
naïvement va vous regarder quelqu'un
différents voiture est il différent mais
il y aura pas de jugement par rapport à
la différence là dessus
tant que la du temps que le jugement lui
est pas inculquer un thé ou qu'ils aient
pas grandi dans le jugement lui mais la
john wayne
non c'est sûr ça sans bobo tous en scène
c'est comme jean claude gauvreau qui
disait qu'on a peur de ce qu'on connaît
pas dans le fond si je sais de la peur
parce qu'on sent attaqué dans nos
certitudes parce qu'on connaît pas
pileux c'est comme une réaction
mais si tu as confiance en toile
toutefois pas d'aller voir l'autre sont
une potence ce quelque chose sur les
réflexions que plus depuis que donne
enfin mettons cette espèce de noms
doivent rester des jeunes non mais tu
sais c'est que je pense à quai à ce même
temps quelle valeur votre transmettre
notre piquet j'imagine que tout y est
passé
- pittis tu réfléchis trop là comme le
monde dans lequel on est dans un camp
dit les réseaux lot est forte conscience
tout le temps d'un mauvais truc aussi
cessé de réfléchir vraiment beaucoup à
ce pense pas que ta première réaction
faire un enfant à moins que tu le vends
pas son nom pour comme en ayant la
réalité de tout film sur le monde avec
mon enfance avait deux choses en main
j'aimerais sortir de l'amateurisme
mais en même temps je pensais c'est bien
comme ça concerne tous au pi 2 pour
l'expliquer à un enfant c'est de faire
comme mais j'explique mon enfant on y
voit quelqu'un différent face que les
réflexes de riz jouent comme des pots et
mais ce pilote de le prendre à port puis
d'expliquer que mais pourquoi questionné
sur piqué comme un genre une
conversation je pense pas qu'ils aient
qu'on ne sait même aller que se tient un
enfant qui recense les personnes qui qui
le remet en caisse
si on fait juste comme non fais pas ça
mais ok mais si comprends pas pourquoi
ils voient pas comme arrêter de le faire
qui souvent quand tu parles tout le
monde a des preuves ou qui contredit un
professeur à l'école jean lui manier
comme heurté parce qu'il fait contredit
le publier comme ça ébranle la confiance
avec le sait comme non venue tout va
être cette élève le qui remettait qui
moi je me faisais un questionnement
sortir dehors des petits même que
j'avais mon bureau cependant derrière
ton héros d'un tube ouest mais
particulièrement unanime comme car j'ai
quand même loin dans les couloirs je
pense que ces professeurs étaient
particulièrement 1 avait partiellement
pas confiance en lui mais qu'est ce que
tu es de se remettre en question était
juste
je faisais rire les gens 6 comme ça m'a
pris du temps mais tant à l'école de
comprendre que c'était pas une joke gens
que l'école était bonne nuit était
persuadé a depuis que 120 maternelle qui
quitte la maison tu es persuadé que
c'est une grosse grosse comme un jeu
parce que l'état vende à l'école de foot
ce qui se joue à l'école mois pile à
réaliser que ce n'est pas un jeu
l'appuyant mascarade
non mais je croyais studio à l'école moi
à 12 la fois que j'ai appris qu'ils sont
importantes mais qui à l'époque je ne
réalisais pas pas tout que cette
importante d'apprendre l'accord du lac
meech le jeu voyait pas l'utilité à
l'epo pourquoi peut-être important mais
oui c'est exact c'est pourquoi c'est la
chose la plus fondamentale
l'accord du lac meech expliquer ce que
semble avoir la prière je voulais aller
l'accord du lac meech pas d'éloges pour
le couac et moi j'ai jamais sue steck
aux babouches excuses mais on va
jusqu'où pc
non mais
enfin les jo clamé ce qui est
fondamental ce que je veux dire c'est de
comprendre pourquoi pourquoi ces
personnages d'apprendre que que la
promesse non justement les costes
absurdes comme pour crocheter si le
baril pourquoi comme toute l'autorité
ouais pourquoi se trouve de morale le et
moralement
steria sec faux-pas dernière manche
aller prendre un café avec une amie puis
on s'est mis à parler d'eux on est tombé
dans le un petit peu le ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure de comme le
questionnement des accroît sa soeur
mettons c'est là ce qu'on fait tout le
monde qu'on fait chez quel est mon
objectif qu'elle est là la fin
l'histoire est ce qu'une fin de
l'histoire tu sais quoi qu'est ce que je
fais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on
fait tout le monde le sait à chaque
matin à se réveiller puis à travailler
pourquoi l'at-il puis cette question là
est extrêmement angoissant quand tu y
réfléchis trottier puis le même principe
mettant de thé pour l'absurdité les
quelque 48 réfléchissez comme tu
réalises tabarnak qui est c'est vrai à
stx a soutenu que si je sais pas bien et
le team attention seconde arme n'était
vraiment posé là la question qu'est ce
que je qualifie si tu mets ton était
vraiment je m'étais posé la question en
solaire 5 à faire de la chimie physique
des maps et en tant que ces pièces fois
qu'est ce que je fais ici mais je te
jure je me posais pas la question tu es
parce que lorsque si on m'avait dit que
cette fois les fabricants n'ont comme on
nous dit que c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est participer au système dans
lequel on est dit mais quand je poserai
la question des quelque chose d'autre
c'est quoi tu sais combien de temps
encore à 100 de penser à tous ceux aussi
et je pense que c'est peut-être l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles il ya
tellement de gens qui adhèrent à la
forme qu'on nous impose
parce que c'est sécurisant qu'on aborde
et des marques et aux seuls puisque
suite et moi.fr fois d'avoir d'avoir de
la lumière dans le nord le déflecteur
qui t'amène
c'est plutôt que d'être comme c'est de
créer son chemin et d'essayer des trucs
de se planter de de recommencer je sais
que le taux de facto norme dans ce que
ça satisfait ce que tu trouves des
réponses à donne un sens qui j'aime
beaucoup ça non mais j'aime auxerre mais
aussi parce que c'est comme inutile et
ultime journée
mais c'est ça tu es comme il faut
arriver à trouver que ce soit ici je
pense maintenant à repenser complètement
utile est complètement inutile comme
tout comme parrain pas de cas ce matin
c'est le dire comme ma musique et ses
épaules le vie continue ouais c'est le
suspense de cosima peut-être ça bonifie
la vie d'autres personnes ou ça ça
envoie du beau mais pour ceux qui le
voient c'est comme dans l'eure qui je
pense que c'est bien de lancer des
choses positives dans l'air en général
je pense pas que met-on réparer une
voiture ou construire une voiture ou
parce que tu es on associe souvent genre
et c'est justement pendant l'homme mais
à la pandémie de mettre les les trucs en
ordre de l'importance il important
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que ouais
mais dans le fond il ya plein de trucs
qui sont nocifs pour plein d'autres
choses qui le sait comme considéré comme
essentiel
ouais c'est qui échoit peu je pense pas
qu'il y ait un ordre le ouais ben ali
comme je vois pas je sais pas c'est
comme des trucs aussi d' expertise t on
à ceux ci
beaucoup les trucs utiles à comme l'
expertise l'étude derrière les choses et
puis j'étais à continuer à fonctionner
le système économique dans lequel il
convient depuis lors y contribuer en
fait leur contribution mais juste pour y
donner les mettons mettons site wafa la
musique c'était juste j'aime ce mais qui
mettons mettons personnes entendez là ta
musique
dans ce sens que ce serait uniquement
pour toi tu le fais si ça ça serait tu
as et où tu dirais même somme qui
manquent mais ça tout seul truc c'est
qu'il faudrait je fasse quelque chose
d'autre à côté puis je sais pas qu'est
ce que je ferai d'autres ne sait sur la
faire mais c'est klaus et c'est le fun
parce que j'aime le faire pour moi ouais
je sais me donne beaucoup de d'énergie
de plein de choses un peu que la
discuter a nommé bien en temps mais je
peux en vivre que je peux le partager
avec des gens c'est comme la meilleure
chaumont ouais c'est la meilleure chose
comme physique et je trouve un peu plate
qui est pas de spectacle c'est que le
moins partagés directement pige pas une
grande fan de nécessairement que de
faire applaudir et adulé ben non mais ce
que j'aime la danse et qui on partage de
quoi tu es c'est cette énergie le mais
je peux non plus quand j'arrête je
manque de me faire applaudir
ouais mais c'est ce qu'est ce que je
vais dire pense que si je t'attendais
dans une autre entrevue que tu mets ton
la chanson gérer les cheveux longs le
truc qui salue vraiment maintenant un
effet concret sur du monde qui ont dit
hey j'ai réécrit à ma soeur le tir dès 2
ans a parlé c'est quand même classement
qu'on crée la chanson ta création de
choses qui n'existaient pas méthon avant
que plusieurs stations au piano pic est
qu'elle arrive peut-être là bas juste
que l'on l'entendre il ya eu du monde
qui sont connectés ce que c'est beau bah
oui c'est beau mais c'est si beau des
trucs qui qui ramène les gens sont en
effet rentrer à tout mais en étant je
trouve ça beau aussi quelque chose qui
sert à rien un bon moyen de méthodes
préférées qui s'appelle viens danser le
haut qui le dit c'est la tonne c'est
juste tout le temps la même chose c'est
comme c'est ok
quelques pas en arrière et quelques
inscrits écoutons depuis longtemps c'est
in town bon je peux payer pas grand
monde que j'ai rencontrés avec qui peut
partager cette fête passée en sorte que
quand je la met les gens en général ils
aiment qui comme ils veulent danser avec
moi mes mails à thoune a dirigé pendant
non avec la musique moi ça fait du bien
ça thiriez cdc dénote une énergie un
joueur qui doit langage universel
les points forts de votre lancée à
l'intérieur d'un bunker jamais tant
qu'on entend transition de verre dont
l'album étant plus concrètement mettant
cette chanson le prince fois j'ai
entendu c'était live au grand talent
était là je te le dis tout petit et tout
à fait l'album d'avant au complet avec
la caisse puis on rappelle traite et le
pis on dirait que je
déjà fan mais quand j'ai entendu ce que
j'ai fait me semble qu'il ya un switch
sans lequel j'ai accès puis choqué tes
chansons ont toujours été personnel
matin sauf que c'était peut-être moins
qu'on tapait ce qu'elles attendent si je
fais toi qui me semble que le gie accès
à chloé le sais pas ce que j'aurais dû
mettre le logo explicite sur la g vu un
mini tellement bon genre le thé comme la
chose de plus utile lorsque c'était
mieux fait plus de rigueur
c'était comme le logo explicite sur les
pochettes des albums des calibres comme
prévu les pochettes d'album can work sur
un groupe de death metal city les
pochettes c'est juste jarret
d'escalettes avec jardin des genres des
entrailles puissant partenaire de jal
épilogue explicite mais bref ça se peut
de sucre est le dernier album day une
approche plus embêtant c'est autre chose
c'est comme ma une approche je sais pas
si j'ai peu plus réfléchi nécessairement
gpo c'est ceci vous notre m ouais je
pense que c'est ce qui est fun aussi
l'on pense que c'est mon premier album
c'est des tonnes que j'écris si dans les
premières tonnes que j'ai écrits dont
j'étais comme si j'avais
dans le couloir où sa grandeur ouais
c'est ça fait qd et c'est juste ça les
choses évoluent comme mon deuxième album
i différents que le premier troisième et
différents seront différents petits ce
qui est drôle aussi c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui veulent alors préféré ça va
toujours avec le premier puis il ya des
gens qui a préféré se trouveraient des
gens qui vont arriver au troisième
tous étaient en grève et ça ne s'invente
pas de préféré mais j'aime beaucoup le
dernier est ce que est ce que tu dis
souvent que toute ta vie pour écrire tes
ton premier album jusque dans fait de ta
naissance qui attend premier album pour
l'écrire dans le fond il a décidé un
jour pippi quand arrive après ce tte
sors ton premier album avec un grand
succès puis la pression dans la forme
tête des attentes [ __ ] à fournir un
deuxième puis éventuellement un
troisième qui et les lads comment est ce
que tu as vécu en fait le processus des
détroits excuse un processus qui étaient
semblables pour toi d'arrivée fort ok
bon je ramasse un mode créatif pendant
six mois puis ce genre avec un album où
c'était différent parce que le dernier
baba dioum j'ai adoré réellement
puis il semble tellement inspiré inspiré
c'est le mot qui me kim bien le plus le
dire tellement d'affaires qui te dis que
c'est quasiment pas possible ça a été
fait et en si peu de temps dont je peux
ça fait dix ans que je suis ben je pense
que le troisième mot pris toute ma vie à
écrire aussi c'est ça la faire c'est
qu'il sait c'est tout ce que tu
j'ai passé les trucs que j'apprends en
vivent les trucs que j'accumule en temps
il ya aussi je pense dans l'écriture le
sentiment d'urgence ce qui est important
que depuis que j'avais vraiment mais je
l'avais aussi avant le deuxième mais le
sentiment d'urgence de dans le sens tout
cas de l'extérioriser quelque chose à
mon besoin de tes la musique ça toujours
est arrivé dans ma vie comme une amie
d'enfance qui était comme ça m'a
vraiment vraiment aider à parler à
nommer des trucs que j'avais la
difficulté que autrement en fait c'est
difficile a nommé parce que le bon tu
parle à quelqu'un ce n'est pas tout dire
à quelqu'un ça va pas fort indique comme
un peu parlé à soi même puis parle à
tout le monde c'est les jeux c'est les
nous c'est pilatus et des jeux qu'ils
étaient toutes ses comptes se confond
c'est tout c'est même une tonne qui dit
je sais c'est paul sais c'est pas juste
de soi qu'on parle très peu
ce que je trouve bien en fait là dedans
parce que c'est clair ce que je dis est
ce que oui
est-ce que tu parles de kant dû faire de
la musique s'adresse vraiment beaucoup
les paroles est-ce que c'est plus
l'écriture ou faire de la musique pour
moi les deux sont la même chose pour
tous les deux font la même chose
et ouais ben comme dans ce sens que j'ai
écrit tout en même temps
ok c'est que
c'est l'impact sur l'autre c'est ce que
ce je pense que j'ai une façon très
intuitive d'écrire je peux comme une
musicienne qui a pris la musique je
comprends pas tant je comprends gens de
l'intérieur puce à l'oreille les trucs
qui se passent même si je sais pas comme
intellectualiser 7 au fameux gip un
cerveau qui est ce que ça a toujours été
comme ça c'est quand la musique est
arrivé dans ma première massa
ça me fascine énormément comment est ce
que la musique est arrivé à toi mais
quand j'étais enfin mais mes parents et
moi mes frères on était on ne suit les
cours de piano qui j'aime bien sûr mais
comme j'avais de la difficulté quand
même à jour j'étais quand même très à
partir de ce moment en fait où j'ai
arrêté de d'essayer d'apprendre des
affaires de des pièces le temps il ya eu
un temps puis la musique est revenue
dans ma vie comme un peu comme petites
choses pour me soulager un genre de
moyens d'expression
mais c'est là que j'ai commencé à
apprendre en fait d'après moi c'est sûr
que le bagage au début mon et
d'importants pays en moi mais comme
c'est là que j'ai vraiment commencé à
apprendre c'est là que j'ai commencé à
jouer du piano d'abord comme que je me
suis surpassé plus aujourd hui à la voix
oscille j'ai appris à chanter en
engrangeant way en faisant me tourne en
composant mitonne fait qu'ils aiment
avoir aussi a évolué nous travailler
trois albums cpm en jeu puis
et mon instinct musical puis le fait que
met-on il ya des trucs j'ai envie de me
déjouer le type de ce que je connais
fait que sur le troisième je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de petits musicalement des
petits trucs de je me dis joue mais qui
hélas sur les trois communes volonté de
sortir de sa zone de confort d'abord
c'est juste aussi avoir phone même
facile ce thème est on moi j'ai fait un
bac en musique puis une demi maîtrise en
musique metal un piquet quelqu'un sans
formation de ces mets ton qui juste par
instinctive par essais et erreurs
arrivent à créer ce que tu cries ça
s'est passé vraiment pas ce que tu
apprécies tu t'amuses et qui es tu es
une complexité quand même le dos et pau
ces pots de la dispose de trois accords
une tc plus prog et par bluetooth un peu
utile fowler qui s'effleurent qu'est ce
tracé puis je pense même si le dernier
de vitesse et les arrangements secoue
toi ça me fascine vraiment que tu as
compris ceux sa sentence en avoir a pris
formellement comment ça marche la
musique jusqu'à c est ce que c'est et la
mettons deviennent vraiment par
elle-même - puis rapidement
c'est quoi le processus parce que moi ça
ça me fascine mais ça m'intrigue aussi
beaucoup de ces parce que à l'ecoute
comme tu dis c'est complexe
c'est l'école de la troisième album 10
ultra complexes mais en fait les deux
premiers aussi puis comment ça devient
maintenant à ce qu est ce que tu entends
c'est ce que c'est mais je sais pas si
ça s'est passé je suis persuadé que
cette expérience il ya un style pour moi
c'est le meilleur mot ouais c'est
l'abandon aussi puis
le pol pot de contrôle en fait le double
contrôle moi c'est comme un peu c'est
les émotions aussi qu'il y ait des trucs
c'est moi il ya une double album que je
me suis dit tu es mettons toutes les
tenues pu imaginer comment tu t'assures
piano pic et supporter quelque chose ça
ne devienne les maladies plug in town
discret mais mettons mélamine je me dis
je sais pas comment qu'elle a composé ce
comment tu t'assois nké tu composes mais
la ligne vers les gens parlent du chemin
à pascal où le frère de dom mais j'étais
avec ce midi puis ça me faisait penser à
au film plaque small je me disais je me
dis ça va tellement dans tout les sens
qu'on dirait que je suis né dans une
petite pièce de square jeu puis je viens
de garder un maximum heures place et
quand une telle image non et en mettant
je dirais que votre casque d'or c'est
plus complexe musicalement qui aimait la
mine comme est justement le mercy avec
la plus haute estime du place du plach
smoltz de l'imposante expliqué mme et
aimait tant mettons que pour le fun on
file chronologie de la création mais la
même thématique et 6 mai tandis que le
sénateur la toune c'est pas mal un riff
de basse dans le fond vous déçu si vous
écoutez en ce moment à peser sur pause à
l'écouté un père venait après fakty
mettons 6 6 mais ton jeu les cheveux
longs c'est six mois quand j'ai réussi
des colts jouer parce que cette tâche à
son piano fait une ligne de bijoux c'est
venu après
geslin faire que troisième album si
c'est que me chercher des synthétiseurs
pas des grosses affaires genre j'ai
commencé avec tes seins joon ho mais
comme la petite boîte
l'extension la bloggie avec un
contrôleur sait pas grand-chose soutien
minimum le même modèle des piles dans le
fond tout mes maquettes ont beaucoup
beaucoup de journaux s'écouter sont
jouées ça pour dire que mélamine mais
c'est drôle je pense c'est comme j'avais
envie de faire quelque chose j'avais
jamais fait qu'ils aient tant du côté de
kate bush
non non non je sais que tout les
français sont encore kate bush
mais pour elle aussi mais non pauvres
non mais j'écoutais jantes dernièrement
j'ai écouté parce que je sais comme
marion je m'ennuie c'est de m'en parler
je suis comme moi j'essaie de te
l'entendre mais la mienne j'ai fait
qu'ils bougent pas d'un 1 ouais mais bon
est-ce qu'elle bush
je pense que oui très forte c'est de
continuer mais ouais mais la mienne je
sais pas je mange avec en même temps un
peu je trouvais ça quand même drôle
d'horaire se remettant un riff la page
avait fait que je te faisais c'est comme
une toune bail qui peut sembler très
premier degré aussi parce que c'est
facile à comprendre c'est comme je pense
que tant comprendre quand je peux
l'expliquer mais ces salaires de des
simples comme mais c'est pop soul c'est
un pas envers moi même
je sais pas il ya comme j'avais besoin
d'un genre de thèmes comme ça mais dont
j'avais envie de parler aussi parce que
c'est quelque chose que en faisant de la
musique et qui dans mes propres nous
ressort un mois c'est comme j'avais
expérimenté ça aussi tu dois être bien
quand on est en moi et c'est chercher
était justement à l'école primaire avec
elle me regarde comme quelqu'un qui en a
tellement que c'est bien le genre parce
que c'est pas trop de questions pièges
que j'aimerais ça et elle s'avère trop
douce fait que je les faisais puis je
pense que sans ce genre de ce sujet de
ce moteur le mettons la muse et qui sert
qui serait pas se fixer comme un peu un
bloc piles attinger crise en une soirée
il s'est très rapidement mais tente fait
une maquette chez vous avec tt
synthétisant des affaires flactif est
comme un jeu d'embryons de ce que ça va
arrêter maintenant
ouais mais c'est pas mal c'était pas mal
c'est une enfance qui est sur l'album ce
qui était bonifiée c'est beaucoup les
son acquittement il ya un peu la faim et
la structure et on l'allongé du pied
comme des couches de trucs qu'on a
ajouté comme une guitare mais donc
j'avais pas fait si maman ne gardez le
le gendarme on le garde et de la
maquette parce que quand et comment
est-on ça se refait pas ce qui va être
fait le son la garde et t il ya quand
même une coupe de tout comme ce que on a
pris les maquettes on
si le vin avec je travaille qui est
coréalisé avec moi pic coréalisé les
troupes les deux autres albums sans fin
qui est vraiment mon collaborateur
je l'aimé beaucoup ben lui a comme mille
clic ou genre ans que structure et le
truc pour qu'on puisse la refaire en
bonifiant les sens dans le fond mais bon
on de pour que ce soit tout de meilleure
qualité
ouais c'est ça tout arrivant sur la
maquette est affecté au go mettant
aurez-vous à tomblaine matin puis elle
ajoute des petites affaires puis c'est
pas mal mais ça dépend nitoo ouais c'est
ça c'est pas tout comme celle là il y
avait celle là puis votre candidat est
formelle toutes les lignes déjà
rangement fait que c'est pas mal un
apport maintenant
la section rythmique genre le drame
parce que moi je t'ai comme charest avec
des défauts drôme pour mélamine j'ai
composé avec un faux drôme puis j'ai
ajouté des gars comme des moments qui
sont un peu comme bossage d'achille -
fait que c'est le pipe était la drôme
eure
il ya tout bonifier sa fille comme lycée
il ya beaucoup composé ses portes en
fait finalement puis allons d'esprit
aussi sépia intense c'est vraiment une
collaboration vraiment le fun parce que
j'avais comme des super bons musiciens à
mes côtés je pouvais comme farah
j'entends cette ligne ne joue simple je
le chante note par note puis leurs joues
mais beaucoup mieux que ce que moi
j'aurais fais tu commences à succès sex
les attentions dans l'esprit le disent
bien en même temps mais le bassiste et
étienne du prix c'est sur une mamie
c'est lui qui a composé cette ligne là
de baisse
parce que moi je suis pas je pense pas
beaucoup à la basse électrique mais
trois jeux jeux plus harmonie mélodies
pis ce puits françoise à hesdin et
guitariste beaucoup plus sur les tons
depuis lectrice est très complémentaire
comme travail qui d'autres tournent
qu'on a fait c'est la maison jaune ça
ressemble quoi lama qui est aussi mais
j'aurais cheveux longs le jouer ensemble
en studio mais je pense qu'après on leur
fait des trucs gens qui comme vous
l'avez tp live genre de bain on le piano
l'atp mettons à a3 et moi jouer le piano
lien qui jouait là
l'acteur barton et un ans qui jouait de
la guitare ou du cndd autre que je sais
pas trop si on ne garde est juste le
piano de ce puits on ne refait les
autres instruments après mes vrais s'est
passé à quel point c'est intéressant
techniquement comment danser dans ce
processus là les paroles deviennent nos
jeunes c'est sur ça que j'accroche pas
ce que c'est
il ya tellement d'affaires dans tes
textes ses boys line symbolisme la part
boot pis comment ça devient ça vient ça
tu apparais dessus tout seul où il ya un
processus d'écriture que tu fais pizza
c'est ça ça m'apparaît c'est débile ça
mais comme c'est moi c'est ça que c'est
sur ce genre bien partir 6ème et si je
parle souvent de l'été c'est c1 et own
way que mettons que ça te mettre dans
cet état là où comme toute école en sa
mais déjà la gauche quitte tu dois être
au courant que si extraordinaire que cet
atelier je me trouve chanceux de pau si
je me verrais mal que pictet qu'un jour
ça va être ça en même temps mais c'est
travailler sur un texte le plan com qui
met par ce compte et nous magique c'est
la crise on dirait mais non on dirait la
peau et la grande poésie
ouais mais en même temps je pense que ce
puits c'est mettons raymond robbe si
j'écoute la première maquette que j'ai
fait c'était pas exactement exactement
exactement se voir mais ça s'en
rapproche à cambrai mais il ya des trucs
c'est que j'ai comme laisser mijoter non
c'est tout neuf c'est comme celle qui
m'a pris le plus de temps à écrire
mettons que as écrit dans le fond dans
ta tête plutôt que sur papier à 500mo
dictionnaire pillés mais on sera déçu
non mais j'en ai un mais mais des fois
je mange mon sort mais comme plus pur
comme écrire pas des toons que tu
parlais tantôt mais juste au dessus de
ce qu the post du la bio de la bible
postuler mais qui expliquait la furie
comment y écrivait c'est une armée
d'hommes et tant pis si c'est vraiment
petit comme toi y ait jamais eu déjà
horaires jeune homme a fait une super g
qui m'ont texte sisi commettons je
trouve marrant d'accord je la fais en
loup pendant une heure piliers des
phrases qui popent tout est toutes
construites et juste des rentrées du
genre de transe méditative le t2 lupi le
sa santé c'est peut-être ça se rapproche
le plus de ce mets tant que la personne
qu'il écrit à côté moi mais moi je sais
pas si c'est comme un peu difficile de
dire exactement
c'est comme je pense faire une étape qui
s'est aussi temps mais y'a comme un
moment où c'est dans la vie où j'étais
un peu genre je me sentais coupable
quand
je n'ai pas en train de faire ce que
parce que j'avais tout en appréciant
j'ai quand même tête que j'ai comme je
pensais à côté ouais
puis j'ai quelque chose que peu de monde
qui on passe à côté
non non un jour peut-être parce que
mettons peut-être qu'il ya rejet à ok ok
ok j'arrête je réécris comme le truc qui
sombra dykstra de sens
puis on est j'ai comme catch et que dans
le fond c'est des trucs que tu en
magasin multi sur les impressions aussi
pu tous se peaufine avec le temps il ya
des trucs je n'aurais jamais été capable
je n'aurais jamais été capable de faire
ça va me il ya deux trois ou quatre ans
arrêté un autre album qui s'est s'est
jamais rien de perdu puis c'est le fait
que en fait du que j'ai conservé tous eu
en moi je pense qui fait que je les
libérer jim pu libérer de cette façon le
au final mais toutes les mamans ou su
vie des gens au dessus de lit des livres
au dessus ou allez vous qu'est ce que tu
fais c'est ce qui fait qu'après six
tasses woippy une bonne tonne car yvonne
se fait juste
je sais pas si je répare les gammas
regard de journée ce qui n'est pas du
tout
c'est comment tisser une fiction qui
comme ses pages e mail avant d'avoir vos
studios et j'en reviens c'est pourquoi
avec eux mêmes mais je les vois juste
dans le sport en mettant je vais comme
faire la même chose pendant trois quatre
mois puis le on écrit juste cavage free
plus jamais la dernière fois quelque
chose quoi je parle
on parlait des des maquettes le pire
dans tout j'ai écouté ton passage à
radio canada et rebecca makonnen
pourquoi puis il ya une tonne qui est
envoyé à maquette
alors oui c'est vrai ben oui censier
dessus ouais ouais c'est depuis la forme
la faune - je passe moi-même à faire
sauf ya un accord qui différentes ça
change tout
bull c'est le second d'albums et parce
que des fois là il ya ça aussi pour cet
album là j'ai comme beaucoup je suis
revenue beaucoup à l'âme inquiète
pendant qu'on pille et même avec les
citoyens ont réécouté je vois la
maquette qui ont été rendus plus loin
dans le processus parce que le magic
était le web mais aussi des fois je sens
me rendre compte change d accord il ya
des trucs que je fais plus pis le jir
écoute l'âme inquiète je fais comme bach
mettant seul je trouve
mettons pour expliquer qu est-ce que
l'harmonie est quelqu'un qui connaît
rien musique pour moi ça serait genre le
maire exemple parce que je pense que
c'est juste qui est relié mettons je
prends cirque et tonalité métier et on
lui d'être un don majeur réside en la
mineur qu'un dommage est ensuite un
accroc majeur l'unité mais duo moment ça
rit c'est comme avec le texte l'émotion
est complètement différente pile atone
au lieu qu'à soi d'orques
et comme les sports comme un des
instants de lumière exact
exact c'est juste comme c'est dans le
fond le titre s'échangeait 1 la province
s'est changé notre vie je suis dans ta
toune ça c'est la différence entre je te
mangerais une toune juste d'une triste
ou une toune avec de l'espoir mais c'est
vrai j'ai envoyé la forme parce que ça
ressemble quand même mais moi j'avais
fait une autre version de la fonte
justement les grosses intérêts peut-être
pour l'équilibré de la loire était pas
sorti en plus moi c'est ce qu'en
centre-ville pour s'abonner ya vraiment
un esthétisme incen le mettons qu'on
parle des clips pour tes gestes du hard
rock comme tel
est-ce que tu avais des idées pour tes
spectacles ce que tu avais des idées de
mise en scène aussi théâtral j'ai
beaucoup fait dans le passé
puis c'est comme devenu un peu je sais
pas j'ai vu beaucoup de gens faire ce
pays comment et si on peut détacher de
ce que j'avais plus envie que ce soit
trop théâtre ou théâtrales métier je
vais bien je veux faire un show
conceptuel le soja vers le spectacle
c'est le cabinet du docteur caligari
puis l'été y avait comme un grosse une
grosse sono
j'y fais aussi la neuve france la
maistrance figurer dans une église
ce téléphone prenons c'était comme a
plutôt que de célébrer dieu on célébrait
la musique y est ça parlait de quel
point on l'a on la maltraite si c'était
bien mais je sais pas mais j'ai envie et
mais wes ma mère ma réponse est vraiment
pas clair mais oui j'ai encore faire ce
travail sur un projet en ce moment
propres prokop mais pas proco biais de
métier qui est qui vaut en tout cas que
tu vas avoir lieu peu importe si
rudement sais pas combien de fois misé
ces genres qu'ovide mais comme on se
sert du comité c'est pas comme un
spectacle serait amoindrie à colonnes
voilà comment est très sombre sur ce
petit souci inspecteurs qui j'aimerais
faire avec du public et mettant aucun si
tout redevient normal plus tard est ce
que c'est ce que tu vas faire au palais
montcalm maintenance passé non ça c'est
un show de couper le gars qui chante et
ça c'est comme le premier show qu'on va
faire avec les mineurs
on ne peut pas encore eu la chance c'est
un peu stressant quand même parce que
habituellement titre fait la pré prod
fait les répètes puis puis le show il se
peaufine petite fête en fait que 20e en
y ça agrandit pied tirant du genre je me
suis l'autre tourner le rendu à qom 120
mails ou et déjà de 80 là on est très
fin c'était savent pas c'est un immense
éclat dès que l'on peut pas le faire
comme tout ce mois là paris puis le
savoyard foot ajoute je sais c'est une
sur cinq il s avère film et pire et
transmis jeu comme patent fans de ce
rapport si c'est nous comme le l'autre
j'ai pu moi c'est ce que je préfère
maintenant je peux pas parler tout de
suite mais acheter vos billets allait
sûrement c'est ouais c'est ça fait qui a
fait l'étude
après les avoir joué en studio d'avoir
je trouve l'on est en pré-production
testo le sait quand même inspecteur qui
équipe un très gros défi n'y a à monter
musicalement mais plus on est cinq à le
faire
sur scène on a fait beaucoup beaucoup de
répète le bientôt on s'en veut en prie
provençal donc ça va être autre chose
puis après on fait le spectacle et j'ai
vraiment hâte qu'on puisse partir anton
et pis on sait le faire vivre sur scène
c'est complètement autre chose et comme
entre commente entrevoit sûr est-ce que
tu es ce que tu est optimiste par
rapport à la situation
je suis là guest du monde actuel il m'a
dit qu'il y ait requis est presque un
vaccin toujours sa confiance à quelqu'un
je n'ai pas tout chez le fils et sont
toujours fiers quelqu'un et que il vient
de montrer je venais juste de l'état
ouais pas complètement
[Rires]
tout est une personne drôle de toute
évidence non pas tu nous fait rire
depuis tout va à l'école c'était
quelqu'un qui faisait rire les gens moi
compris moi en seconde à acheter plus
d'or tu as quand même ce personnage là
aussi un peu comique ne serait-ce que de
remercier messmer par exemple en gagnant
abriter c'est juste quelque chose qui
qui qui adhèrent kaki qui est drôle est
ce que la guerre était juste one tipi
dans les textes
ton dernier album on est un peu de
comédie ce que je me trompe
bien peu d'humour malgré la noirceur des
thématiques juste dans les images
certaines images sont justes carrément
drôle utile comme quoi en faudrait plus
je m'en souviens je me souviens juste
mettre pas sur les commentaires parce
que ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
plusieurs quand même plusieurs fois dans
l'album d'affaires comme quelle image
drôle ans que oui elle comme
le truc est un peu à me présenter ici
même mes passions musicales
je demande juste mentionné sur le 6e c
où vas-tu quand tu dors à me faisait
rire le parce que je me dis il est tout
le temps en faisant je sais comment
c'est là tout d'un module beaucoup psy
comme un peu de pousser au fond l'idée
de télétoon pop qui maquille pas vous
donner de l'importance à la quand il n'y
a plus d'idées le disciple quoi faire
comme pour comme année faire lever la
tout à fait moduler kg c'est comme moi
ça donne toujours l'impression qu'ils
sont en train de s'envoler avec le moi
je le fais comme ça module mais dont six
fois à la fin c'est comme ça modules en
route samedi dans un box à mesure de
piloter comme je comprends plus rien
fait que ça ça me faisait rire mélamine
ça me faisait rire aussi quand même même
sa part de thé ça veut pas dire que si
elle est dedans musique que la tournée
passerune annonce est ce exact
exact mais c'est comme ça c'est injuste
j'ai eu un flash d'une image que je me
rappelle ma 10 crèmes sont les joies
paraphraser parce que je me rappelle
plus exactement mais c'était et mangent
ou et bouffe des abeilles parce qu'elle
aime trop le miel tu ya quelque chose là
dedans quai comme absurdes qui comme à
la fois humoristique mais dramatique
aussi s'est fait qu'il commet cette
espèce de dualité des réalisateurs comme
inutilement simple triste mais il ya
quand même du sourire dedans parce que
c'est que l'idée de la rumeur en fait
c'est lui qui parle de la rumeur puis
à quel point tout le monde exagère le
ski c'est le bouche à oreille que c'est
comme poussée à l'extrême c'est pareil à
manger mais ya de ça c'est vrai qui est
ce ouais c'est cool parce que c'est
notre cochon de lait mais moi j'aime je
pense sites comme je trouve l'humour
c'est sans importance j'ai beaucoup de
difficulté avec les gens qui ont peu
d'humour
des fois je comprends pas ce qui se
passe loin c'est ça ça phoques le
cerveau soit un job la personne fait
qu'un mât continue a déclaré je veux
dire une grossièreté
c'est simple ce qui se passe ou si qu'un
quand trimestre mais ce match en ma
compagnie
c'est plate parce qu'elle a été obligée
oui mais pourquoi tu en parles moi c'est
comme si après catchy c'est ton problème
là dessus il faut comme tu expliquer
encore 4 le niveau et tout le fait que
les requins football sont moins fan de
gaga je pense que je pense qu est en
tout cas ceux qui ont plus d'humour font
plus vont saisir quelque chose de plus
mais tu penses tu peux aimer ce même si
le beau temps sur ippon tant que c'est
juste mais 80 91 tout coule de chloé
pelgag cellule n'est pas partie de la
proposition
quand même mais moi j'aime ce avoir du
plaisir
des fois parce que si j'ai souvent
l'impression aussi quand tu fais de la
musique c'est comme si tu es le monde
constamment les choses
que dépeint un maurice le trait la
musique c'est une blague
comme m bon elle t-elle vraiment
reptilien j'avais comme un joker en
france et qu'un quelqu'un qui
interviewent et pilot qui ont parlé il
sait il parlait du fait qu'il n'ait pas
entendu et reptilienne piloter comme je
veux pas trop en parler
non et qui sait pas d'ailleurs mais
c'est juste un extrait que j'avais comme
poster s'appuie le sait ces malades
c'est y ait des gens qui trouvent ça
drôle le métier du monde que c'est comme
voilà des commentaires sur un truc de
marketing et j'ai une maladie diorama
katyn est trop grosse ça fait bizarre
sur internet
à bercy on a parlé longtemps moi je me
dis comme celle à cette année l'homme
est ce mal et c'est comme acquis ouais
c'est bien d'ailleurs regarde la hausse
est beaucoup plus bizarre si vous voyez
de mon côté de la caméra ce moment 5 en
plus pesant que ce que l'islam un
complexe applaudissements des trophées
ou 16 ans tellement je comprends pas
j'ai beaucoup de difficultés avec cette
affaire le thé des trophées puis tout en
mettant ça fait tellement ça fait
vraiment plaisir à voir des
reconnaissances injuste que c'est
bizarre mais c'est un contre-temps
concept la compétition de bosses c'est
quelque chose qui ont la dent société si
omniprésent l'on veut tout le temps un
gagnant et si on veut toujours on peut
jamais forêt remettons est tchèque tout
c'est mettons toutes ses joueurs de
basket l'os sont tout bon essayons tout
est excellent ya peut-être pas un
meilleur de tous les temps on s'en fout
ça dérange poletti commun
meilleur où je sais pas - comme c'est un
drôle de truc puis mais est ce qui en ce
qu'il faut qd up ou si c'est en fait de
vos raquettes à quel point il ya
beaucoup de monde qui croise c'est donc
j'ai pas de cadeaux à des gens c'est
bien je trouve ça bosse mais la culture
la compétition dans ce qui est qui
omniprésente dans la musique ne serait
ce qu'avec la voix à m et puis il y
avait un clip sur youtube c'est c'est un
montage très bref délai dans la voiture
place et bob dylan qu'elle chante le
tuvalu cela des réactions cher des juges
sont là où est la proposition selon bain
et on la voit ici une afa qui font au
moins c'est que c'est pas juste mettons
un seul type de voix thématiques comme
toutes sortes de différents styles de
chanteurs yannick on dévoie vraiment
inhabituel qui sont là mais ça reste pas
un concours des créations de mode est là
mais ça reste divertissement
divertissement ça reste supporter paul
ausick émettons c'est quand même si
quand même si c'est comme une
interprétation non sens que si tu vois
pas la mesurer comment quelqu'un je t'ai
bob dylan si ces textes sidnei oui moi
je trouve ça grave est après tout je
suis capable de sumette et oui sauf que
de ses propres et de ses propres tourner
c'est surtout celui qui donne sens tu es
tu es la meilleure par personne pour
ponctuer ton propre truc parce que tu
sais si c'est comme complètement
connecté à temps quand on sait qui est
6e
safran pas sa lutte en tout cas
compagnie de jean leloup parce que
j'avais la perche l'eau joppy jorda les
deux dernières semaines j'étais
comblement absolument l'autre d'hélène
chose est que écouter écouter le
defender of the line est une obsession
c'est que moi avec le plat que le
paiement de 40 ans à sortir le cpie lui
le justement ce n'était un qui en
entrevue il ya un vraiment bon signe de
squeeze et de compteurs sur bob dylan
le no direction home petite voix près de
d'entrevue petit justement ces questions
absurdes l'altix fait posée par un
journaliste qui soit connaît pas ça ou
soit si c'est la même question étaient
douze mille fois à tes pieds il y laisse
jamais passer
il va trouver une touriste de tdf
d'accuser la l'absurdité du moment puis
de la question petit fils c'est marrant
mais c'est ça qui sait si magique
l'instrument précieux c'est un truc
vérité c'est jallet qui ont cet esprit
le de le reconnaître
suite quelque chose il faut t'y c'est
son enfance et comme sa maman lui fait
déjà je les ramène son or et zac efron
est alors moment il est en fuite aura un
shooting photo le type nettoyer mal à
l'aise puis le genre si lunettes puis le
photographier
j'en mettais mes lunettes dans ta bouche
rire avec thibaut quoi
[Rires]
de plus il faut les mettre dans la
bouche du coach a demandé jean coutu
voudrait faire ça regarde et outillés
pour faire que je sais pas si c'est mal
de réagir comme ça on attends t'es tu
vois tellement pas de monde naturel dans
la télé quand kobe ça fait longtemps
j'ai regardé les mais ça a changé mais
je sais pas c'est l'impression que j'ai
je peux m'aider à maximiser sa phase
disant sa peau même échanges
maintenant je le regarde juste quand je
vais dans le coin dans le bas-du-fleuve
le moyen télé qui est à même d un des
mérites des derniers endroits au québec
qui ont la télé
mon préféré c'est les pubs de rivière du
loup les pubs comme une hauteur jamais
écouté la voix par rapport à ceux c saf
et mettons deux ans de prison ferme pas
de casse un peu plus moi je pensais que
pour faire de quoi parler dans un micro
falek taille une diction parfaite soit
bonjour tout le monde bienvenue à la
nana toi comme ceci dit on a commencé à
le faire plus je me suis je veux quand
même pas essayé de faire c'est pas ça
doit être trop y de pitt se seraient pas
bons rice à date ça méritait le monde et
il remplit son projet mais pourquoi
est-il si comme tout le monde
moi je me suis une première fois chez
cauet
pourquoi est il normal c'est quoi ça
c'est comme mes mains je me reconnais
mais je sais une première fois qu'ils
aient j'ai fait une entrevue le gt comme
complètement moi ça prend du temps mort
mais des fois j'ai été soumis pendant
trois semaines mais pauvre s et je
trouve cette oeuvre des fois comme fou
l'éclairage pileux
mettons les yeux qui pensent à autre
chose souvent petit un sourire démesuré
mais comme ça se passe
ce avec la caricature trop laid trop
gros test clé les vouvoie m'appeler
alors vous klô pelgag sas jamais
beaucoup pierre falardeau jamais seul
vous comme j'aime coup-ci entrevue où ça
rit ça ira t il rien aux bronchites le
métier comme du riz sans foule de ce que
les gens vont penser comme ils y
assument que bon il du monde sont là et
puis j'écris juste pas ce sont des pieds
comme nicollin c'est correct pis ça
prend du courage en crise face s'est
passé du courage ou quand même je sens
mais l'excès a les mêmes mais je pense
un laisser-aller puis maintenant le même
principe que quelqu'un qui qui adressent
les situations juste parce que y est pas
il fait juste laisser aller 10 10 qui
pensent maintenant tu étais dans une
dette pluie quelque chose qui tombe un
peu à quoi il peut de faire enfin ce
starcraft juste comme d'adresser cette
situation là parce que tu le sens où nos
filtres sans se paie à la place de jaude
comme les deux est un peu en cours dans
dans la conversation faire que moi mais
c'était bizarre ce exact doute aimé ton
juste je pense à les louanges qui a tout
le monde en parle dit qu'il était comme
clairement nerveux le guet fait c'est
quoi t'es tu veux tu t'en aller vite sur
carte abonde beaucoup l'effet ben je
regarde ma montre
quand je suis nerveux bien en ce moment
j'ai pas mal nerveux dieu merci de me
coller devant québec au complet
je reconnais clairement il ya peut-être
oublié qu'il ya du monde pour qui c'est
pas naturel
c'est lui qui a grandi dans cette
affaire la télé l'oubli jeudi c'est
tellement pas naturel tout à faire la
queue c'est juste de parler de soi sans
cesse c'est pas naturel de titres
intériorise pour lancer la conversation
de l'autre bord comme punk on verra si
c'est un drôle de truc touag il ya du
monde étrange c'est en toi ton processus
créatif c'est juste un spécialiste dans
le domaine de telara surcoût qui se fait
poser des questions d'histoire qui
regardent putois guillaume en savoie la
maison c'est le but dans le sens qui est
si c'est comme plein de trucs en fait
et moi j -p autant envie de m'habituer à
ça mais en même temps je contente d'être
moins proche qu'avant parce que c'est ça
en moins avec le pire mais ça quand tu
vois lillois je m'attends à être nerveux
je compatis pas ce que tu dis moi je
pensais pas ou du bâton wahiba moi
j'avais vu ce mail ouais je sais pas je
comprends qu'il peut devenir octobre
parce que tu étais malade - sion un
temps surtout quand la personne est un
peu agressif dans ses questions qui te
sens pas nécessairement comme des fois
même si oui je voulais pas parler trop
vite et mais as-tu déjà regardé tout le
monde en parle avec ayem à temps plein
avec mozilla requins oui oui mais
pire chose que je sais on est conscient
que tu peux être invité et pas
nécessairement parce que tu es apprécié
je pense que c'est le cas pour moi
maintenant mais c'est quand même quelque
chose qui existe c'est quoi puis les
questions sont quand même fait en
entrevue l'on parle à tout le monde en
parle mais entrevue en général date il
est question sont quand même de chez
pictet pas tout le temps à l'aise de
répondre à toutes ces questions là
j'imagine c'est des questions mettons
sur un album comme comme le tien kiki
quand même personnel paie qui par votre
quand même direct et si j'en sais j'en
parlais du 7e levier c'est le site pour
répondre à une question faut que tu
fasses je vous réponds moi c'est ça fait
qu'ils disent ou tu la laisses le jard
belge préféré ne pas en parler il faut
se faire mettre à jour pour été autre
chose par rapport à la question puis je
suis parti sur autre chose beaucoup qui
font ce billet c'est dur moi j'aime pas
quand ça devient une sensationnaliste ou
si c'est comme deux actions de sulfite
qui aimait tant c'est un minimum quand
tu avais un un pigeon qui est temps déjà
je des trucs dans la maison pour com
quel monde est pour toi puis que ça
tombe ça 30 sympathique parce que je
fais pitié un peu de sa sphère le fait
que c'est mon album ça parle quand même
de ce qu'un bain une part de darkness et
qu'est ce que je fais parler de l'album
je peux parler des exactement pourquoi
tout les trucs puis c'est puis en étant
petit je trouve ça enlève aussi à
l'oeuvre dans le sens où si tu les
coudes vraiment toutes les réponses
ce conseil doit être tes réponses puis
en même temps moi je veux que les gens
soient capables de laisser errer leur
pensée là dedans pis de s'approprier le
thriller trop près de reportages à ce
soit réalité méthodes et qui tu parles
d'un j'aurai les cheveux longs plus
important on s'en fout c'est des kits
pas non mais dans ce sens qu'ils savent
faire
les potentiels effets que ça fesse la
banque il l'entend si les rétractations
mélamine monde et on a discuté aussi à
contre aa entre juste faire comme il
faut nécessairement premier au premier
roi c'est comme mélamine où il ya plein
de tounfit aurait laissé ça parle
beaucoup de moi aussi mais ça parle
aussi d'expérience mais ça va beaucoup
nous essentiellement de deux mois mais
me dis parce que je suis la personne que
je connais le mieux
mais si ce seuil en ait beaucoup dans
l'âme et à la mise aux normes ainsi fait
puis c'est ce pour faire une toune city
méthode peut être plus vives se piquent
tâtonne s'assoit sur notre inquiétude
peu à peu amplifié pis pour vous faire
une bonne toune web et il ya des gens
qui sont
qu'ils sont capables de se détacher en
fait du truc puis d'écrire pour d'autres
personnes puis avec exactitude si je
trouve ça comme c'est impressionnant
c'est comme comme un auteur un romancier
serait capable de comparer la réalité
d'un autre puis d'ouvrir la brèche sur 7
c'est super impressionnant vraiment
beaucoup de d'empathie à guise ouaip
hideux de recherche
oui foot kahn reste il faut que tu sois
capable de mettre à la place d'un petit
il faut qu'on soit
qu'on y croit c'est à ton histoire
qu'est ce ça pour être touchés c'est ça
la foire puis j'ai l'impression que
souvent là c'est vraiment c'est mon
opinion à moi de quelqu'un qui
quitteraient beaucoup plus sur les
auteurs compositeurs interprètes que sur
les interprètes ne tombent en général
dans ma mamie goût personnel puis puis
moi moi on dirait que ça se ressente
zain moi ce qui me fait triper le plus
c'est quand tout seul la totalité était
quand même temps j'entends un ou une
interprète faire une chanson qui c'est
impossible ce soit lié à cette personne
là parce qu'on on connaît maintenant sa
ville si tu connais la personne psy que
jamais elle vécut se mettant le tir il
joue vraiment pas dire de nom parce que
ça me tente pas de pointer personne du
doigt le dessus mais ça m'arrive de
faire que ça marche potes c'est ce qui
apparaît pour moi parce que vraiment
l'entièreté du 9 puis ses programmes
pour ce que je suis très beau temps sur
ton art à toi c'est c'est l'intégrité
complète bachelot qui fait qu'elle tout
tout tout se complète j'imagine bien
tout va ensemble ces seuls en ce que
dans ce que je fais du moins et je
trouvais ça intéressant aussi chose
quelque chose qui est plus difficile à
faire comme aujourd'hui métier comme
réjean ducharme seuil avec 1,2 photo le
de lui il y en a une qui abaisse jardin
public son chien qui est souvent de
hockey c'est comme lui y'a jamais fait
il semble d'entrevue je pense pourrait
jamais il jamais les récolter ses prix
tu avais aucune des équipes qui étaient
y est mort il ya pas longtemps tout
comme hôte et je trouve ça quand même
extraordinaire que c'est comme un
fantasme de pouvoir voir ses piètres que
c'est fou sorti sa maman à ce point là
c'est que ça demande un effort dans le
sens inverse le de vouloir garder
l'anonymat tout prix se maintenant tu
étais déjà le fonds doit cesser
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça se pourrait le
sait peu sur ma peau c'est ça s'est
passé ces six complices et complexes
maintenant de ne pas avoir son image ne
parle pas il aurait fallu bien du moment
j'aimerais mieux peau qui à l'article
une photo comme de ceux sur qui en ce
moment faudrait qu'il fallait juste que
tu passes par proxy le statut ça
pourrait pas être ta femme qui te
représente le disque irait trop de façon
de revenir jusqu'à tout faudrait que tu
envoies mettons à chaque fois tu
finisses manuscrites en voiture à
quelqu'un tu connais pas qu' aucun lien
avec toi tu as voyages une adresse non
un tricheur pis ça casse comme fauteuil
aux banques si mettons le tic est en
avance de 2,2 dans les rues de dégâts
physiques et anonyme puis may et ultra
reconnu maintenant passé qui on a des
doutes mais il ya des exemples mais un
peu l'exemple mais il n'y a pas
d'exemple ya de ces exemples mettons au
québec contemporain
au québec je pense que les gens ne
chantent pas mal d'exemples slick
l'heure de faire la musique sans avoir
ta face nulle part il ya le tue qui sont
mettons au masque et outils dès demain
les guides des guns girls village
pendant longtemps on savait pas
exactement cette équipe que tant qu'on
apprenne que sous tutelle goldblum
huawei mettre au québec existe us
démasqué au québec des jarres de pièces
l'est afin qu'on sache le lien qui avait
essayé le quai kiki gaborit choisi mais
ça serait un tour de force a créé
salaires des réseaux sociaux des capable
de faire ça parce que c'est tellement on
est tellement dans l'image
ouais c'est et ses serrures que ça va
comme sur la page instagram de quelqu'un
pile où jusque là personne n'a pas de
parent c'est grave c'est super grave
parce que les producteurs souvent ils
veulent qu attendait une parce que c'est
devenu un moyen quand même de rejoindre
un petit que tu veux sur la page puisque
pas tout le temps dans tout le corps et
la phase de la personne seror parce que
c'est juste que ton cerveau il fait tu
apprends que le monde préfère quant à
face et le fait que tu es tu apprends
que dans le fond c'est ce que ce pipe
l'aspi le ca deviens mind et pourtant tu
écris c'est une manière de devenir
immortel dramane groggy mais elle est
saine et émettons coopaga kaka sera plus
ça parle mais quelque chose de
copenhague qui va encore exister
est ce que mon vrai que les albums de 80
on l'espère mais je suis morte
j'aurais préféré laisser comme pas de
trace
ah ouais tu disais ça danse charpente
mais je peux venir show du métro non
mais c'est juste parce que j'ai fait un
podcast hier aussi pileux et jeux comme
bon c'est toutefois moins ici les
flammes en a moins rigolé mais simple
non mais c'est juste de envoyé plein de
quantité de trucs de moi qui parle de
deux enfants sans intérêts et mettons
nous te connecter ce un jour pour faire
genre j'ai juste pour ne pas être
d'accord enfin guillaume marion ta
gueule mais intense souvent quelqu'un
fait comment tu as dix à sept fois la
plus choquant encore d'accord c'est
rohff l'egypte chiche
mettons que je content d'être encore
d'accord mais si je te laisse des places
tu laisse des traces aussi de tes
erreurs potentielles de noeuds
je sais pas où tu imagines si j'avais
et 14 ans me planter comme toute ta vie
est comme son entrevue de chaque âge et
toi petit mais je les gens riches de
plus d'écouter l'album que des entrevues
mettons que fait à 25 ans telle place
laissé très peu mais les corréziens
justice ces gens qui parlent angoisses
mes balles et ceux qui s'est réglée pas
de place pour cette petite en god merde
lol on s'en fout même temps metz
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment c'est
peut-être c'était complètement faux ce
que dit m je pense qu'ils mettent oms
qui drive ou à beaucoup de monde à créer
puis à procréer si d'engendrer quelque
chose de quelque chose qui perdure de
toi
une partie du toit qui continue
d'exister pendant que tu existes plus
mes skis
ce qui me fait capoter moi c'est mettons
des oeuvres du moyen-âge a donné le ton
en appelant m
émettons des murales super célèbres
anonymes outils des piges genre fait pas
on tire maintenant aujourd'hui en direct
de pau signé ton à vendre et si ce n'est
sur dix est limité mais c'est comme non
à cette époque là c'est comme cette
recette à la régence noté dans ses yeux
deux fois moins d'intrant mais ces
sommes c'est comme la personne son nom
on aurait pu mais tant qu'on aurait pu
être dans les livres d'histoire mais il
serait pas parce qu'il fait non si tu
avais un site avait décrit remettons le
la façon dont on enlève toutes les
règles du jeu comme on le connaît si on
enlève tout là toutes les constructions
qu'on s'est fait comment comment tu
vivrais tons or pitavy maintenant est ce
que ces cimes et on enlève toutes les
deux
faut que tu fasses d'apparitions
publiques il faut que tu t' il faut que
tu participes à ou au système
comment tu sais ce que tu serais tu
ferais sûrement des spectacles encore
j'imagine mais ce que tu serais
masqué déguisé est-ce que tu caches
rillettes à personne j'aimerais juste
que l'image est un peu moins
d'importance que j'aimerais que le
milieu de la musique soit plus grand
dans le sens où qu'on ait plus de
diversité que ce qu'on considère comme
on de groupies de gauche ça soit à
l'adisq mettons j'aimerais c'est que ce
soit il ya plus de de surprise c'est
qu'il ya plus de gens qui puissent dans
le fond ce que je pense c'est plus un
truc collectif que que pour moi même
comme vous je peux pas me plaindre de
savoir quand même bien jeu comme des
trucs inquiétant dans ce milieu quand
même tu es quelqu'un me disait que
maintenant il y avait des auteurs des
gens qui travaillaient que pour créer
une toune pour des playlists qui
rentrait pour une playlist puis je suis
pas je trouve ça un peu comme nous
c'est plate mais je pense ce genre de
truc là ça a toujours existé de façon le
fardeau de faire de l'argent avec une
personne puis de faire d'argent avec dès
lors le ça a toujours existé mais mais
ça m'a toujours déprimé c'est toutes les
histoires d'avant c'est la jeune
chanteuse interprète qui met des tonnes
et des tonnes piqué
théâtre avant sa fin qui a le plus rien
pied est sous la tutelle de son père qui
s'occupe de ses enfants
je trouve affreusement triste gisait sur
ben je sais comme romain gary puis je
lisais sur jean seberg aussi l'actrice
qui était sa femme qui qui c'est une
actrice française qui a vécu aux états
unis tout puisse à son tour ils se
marrent triste mais c'est comme
l'histoire de plein de plaine jambes de
voler en fait l'image est quelqu'un puis
c'est quoi son histoire mettant tous les
réseaux mais à le jouer dans jeanne
d'arc
ça a été son premier rôle quand elle
avait 17 ans est parti de sa ville
natale est arrivé mettons dans le grand
monde du cinéma du show business pile a
finalement été très mauvaise dans le
film jackass et fait descendre par par
la critique et tout ensuite un peu plus
tard bas et c'est aller à s'en est
remise un peu mais tu sais pas si tu as
fait pile après allez allez jouer dans
un film de jean luc godard c'est
vraiment mieux parce que j'ai un blanc
de mémoire aucun de ses puits titre mais
c'est le monde feront leurs recherches
si et le moment parce qu'elle me tends
mon frère mais celui ci aille je suis en
train de me perdre
jouer dans le film de godard prêt à
remonter un peu son son
son truc passé comme la figure de la
nouvelle vague d'enfants qui devenu
après avoir joué dans d'autres films
c'est comme paul et des grands succès
préserver des liens avec les bacs
panthers puis tout seul
t comme poursuivi par le fbi âge ça en
images étaient un peu trop salie peas a
toujours été comme quelqu'un son image
il appartenait pas d'en lancer comme une
nouvelle tout le temps puis bal été
retrouvée morte dans un camp de fass en
mai comme ça a été dit comme un suicide
de trop dans celui des étrangers même si
juste six ans pour important le géant
conditions le mi6
c'est quoi le lien avec spotify l'enfant
remettez les désaxés définitivement
l'image qui qui qui dicte la sphère de
l'image que j'ai quelque chose de
malsain qu'un que c'est ce qui inquiète
id tête à produire des personnes
tatouées était une référence à britney
spears le ticket acheté sous la tutelle
d'un belge de l a été pris à dos tri
mais enfin on qui ont fait une star on
fait son image en écrire s'étonne t tout
est fabriqué la baisse est elle irritée
loges durée squatter ans en ski et ça ne
s'arrête complètement ruiné sa santé
mentale salotti sens ça a été bon ça a
profité amplement mais apparemment
profité à ldc ça c'est comme de faire de
quelqu'un un produit mais pas si pressée
soir puis je parlais de ce musée qui
mais je pense que ça existera toujours
ce truc le sait que en fait c'est la
même chose quelqu'un qui travaille pour
pendant des années pour une compagnie
dans lequel les payer pour respecter
mais je continue avec eux parce qu'il va
être fidèle peut avoir sa retraite t1
fait utilisé dans un truc tu es tu
donnes dont alain à à quelqu'un puis ça
après quand tu finis
de deux c'est ton travail tu arrives à
la retraite et j'ai pas l'impression que
c'est le cas quand même beaucoup souvent
c'est comme l'arrivée en retraite
chapeau quoi faire c'est parce que la
personne n'a pas découvert c'est quoi ce
qui le passionnait
mains des démunis toujours été dans un
taux toujours été placé toujours suivi
la ligne
les publicités et a10 qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que tu t'achètes avec l'argent tu
fais puis crée des besoins cliente a
tout d qu'est ce que j'aime dans le fond
je sais pas ce que j'aime c'est comme ça
c'est comme au vertige cantal
quand arrive l'heure j'imagine qu'ils
sont en parle paul dans l'idée qu'on
t'envoie t il faut juste qu'ils étaient
une voiture ta famille que tu
correspondent à plein de choses
bref je vis metz je pense qu'alors ça
amène comme une lumière là dedans petit
j'aime entendre parler des gens comme
jean leloup fait bon se cacher derrière
je fais facof suis parti c'est comme ça
donne ça peut donner des idées au ca du
monde qui sont pas tout à fait tort
c'est un secret qui triment jean leloup
c'est ainsi non il ya mes amis sont son
bo passe d'un guitariste classique puis
fait des tournées de bons souvenirs je
vois joue partout dans le monde l'était
vraiment concertiste de lecteurs que la
sexy puis lui trip sur victor il ya
comme jean victor ancienne aujourd'hui
7e 18e siècle et olivier victor de de
lüthi phi phi jean-louis chez ma mère
ils y achètent des guitares à david puis
jean louis s'est pointé pire parties de
guitare du team ses adducteurs
apparemment jean david il y avait
peut-être imposant avec le gie vendu de
8h à jean leloup aujourd'hui thé puis
devant le comité m ou si martin guitare
moi j'achète victor album qu'est ce que
qu'est-ce qui sans rien pour toi qu'est
ce qu'on doit dire ce que tu connais ton
album de noël qui sort le 22 mai j'écris
n'est l'année passée je pense que je
t'ai écrit les paroles c'est au prix
d'une tonne qui existait comment
commencer ça me fascine parce que j'ai
tenus si c'est suffisant stevens qui a
sorti des albums noël mais c'est comme
vendre des chansons avec la toyota
qu'est ce qui fait que maintenant
beaucoup la qualité elles donneront les
enfants sur le sapin et de balle les
cadeaux non c'est une toune qui dit et
qui parle de quelqu'un qui est seule à
noël c'est une triste honneur que me
plaît de noël c'est vivre de joni
mitchell
ah ouais bah oui c'est ça qui m la
question reste la question demeure de
qu'est ce qu'une bonne humeur à
paraphrase le thème de vivre le vin dans
sa fonction serait alors que vous êtes
connecté puis johnny veut à l'écouté
réécouter la une personne mais oui c'est
vrai et oui samedi de quoi ça de quoi là
tout cela m'a fait changé mais c'est
elle que la gélatine de noël
le vent existait on a tous le droit des
essais libres de droits ça passe et les
clins d'oeil sera pas seul je mens smith
et dans l'intro way dans les trous dans
les paroles aussi a dit genre de crise
mais sans vie
[Musique]
à ma question qu'est ce qui fait qu'une
tonne de rmc que ça c'est clairement de
termes de vivre sa famille disent que ça
donne des ailes
mais commencer les chansons de noël sont
devenus les chansonneurs ben ça c'est la
bonne car les paroles bon à la plupart
parlent de noël de faut que ça parle à
nos jeunes enfants il ya pas d t de
presse je pense que d'autres affaires
moi je pense qu'ils aient souvent à
l'eau il est souvent des grelots ces
bétons à la bonne fée crise mais saisie
ou le lait grelotter 60 vélos
pis dans la composition c'est beaucoup
c'est souvent comme un peu de temps lors
de jazz t mettons l'harmonie et hippie
la forme fait que tout c'est l'âme a
rassemblé font que ça fait tonner des
pratiques à connotation religieuse aussi
été mais tantôt layton de noël pop du
temps de noël chrétien maintenant je
t'aime en se fiant stevens et religieux
à fort worth et pop
mais les chrétiens et émettant minutes
ya une tonne de noël c'est la merde ça
viendrait qu'en faire un album de noël
mais oui ben vas-y toi pas go by non
valable mais ouais non merci
quoi c'est pas dans la gamme arcole
tribaux à ben folds et comme si jamais
vraiment
et ces vols d'abord avant de clore le
but qu'on parle de higuain je fais trop
mehdi karnas tabac à chiquer soient
égaux fait des vidéos sur youtube s'est
pas maintenue 20 ans qui fait des
milliers d'albums ce programme a à ce
jour
aujourd'hui la les critiques d'albums le
plus influent dans le monde à aiguèze
les plus influents qui vous est faite en
vidéo son album sic
c'est incroyable je connaissais dessus
avant avec sa soeur et moi j'avais vu tu
avais un minute avait postic avait
commencé à être suivre j'en suis sûr à g
je trouve mais moi je connaissais mais
je les connais les pigeons un angle qui
je sais que sylvie que un peu popularisé
by populariser un album de dorures parce
qu'il ya une très bon rugby ou pire que
medhat rien il fait ça pour plaire
artiste mtv les trucs vraiment strini
aussi prend des artistes qui trouve
vraiment bon puis ça les aide vraiment
première fois que c'était comme en
france et un truc et puis ils adressent
campo fait pas je le laisse en france et
fait juste comme paris comme toutes ces
autres
mouais mais comment tu penses qu'ils se
trouvent
je pense que je vais beaucoup de gens
quand l'album est sorti
ben je cite la musique un rythme de 6
son talent et de sa jeunesse en mal trié
ok web sso c'était la même chose s'est
passée la théorie à mon frère c'est que
mon frère ce genre le plus grand flou
quant à nous on est inquiet puis il dit
il ya beaucoup de trucs mais dans le
truc plus obscurs langue et même
interview
si les trucs mais tant qu'ils sont
vraiment bien cotés sur itunes music
pivot souvent voir le sait que les trucs
que le monde aime qui connaît pas piller
côte lycienne soleil fait mes vieux
jours
moi je pense qu'il y avait comme un gros
intérêt sur ce truc
le puits puis comme je sais pas trop
pourquoi jean cet album là parce que les
deux autres on peut qu'y puis-je des
gens qui m'écrit qui m'ont écrit
et qui dit qu'en commentaires jean louis
joue notre dame des sept douleurs je
sais pas s'ils doivent pas être des
milliers avoir fait ça n'ont plus fait
que moi et mes on est signée marc ferro
et puis sachez qu'un seul tout ça en
même temps qu'il te parle de sortie
comment tu sais quoi qui s'est passé
pour toi tu as tu fait déjà omagad quand
même parce que c'est tellement rare t1 à
musique en france elle au québec c'est
c'est tellement si un petit milieu comme
puis ça sort pas beaucoup de lui comme
souvent un peu en france
avant france mais il ya aucun artiste
québécois en france même si souvent on
arrive à essayer de te le faire croire
mais ça explose jamais à pas les seuls
trucs qui ont vraiment explosé c'est les
cowboys fringants
je pense qu'il ya le truc aussi très
exotique en plus loin pour eux dit
bakker des pirates le premier album mais
sinon le genre y en a pas vraiment fait
qu on est très comme ici même canada
anglais on voit rarement et les états
unis en camp - donc il était pour moi
j'étais comme ces malades fatigués des
effets immédiats et suppléments qui ont
suivi soudainement max
pas tant que ça non mais juste content
parce que tu veux dire les gens qui
s'intéressent faut d'abord que ce soit
aussi que s'intéresse à quelque chose
qui pendant qu'elle s'y était un gros un
grand pas pour des gens dont la langue
première et l'anglais puis qui ont accès
à absolument tout dans le monde qui est
fait pour eux ils vont s creed sont
prêts à faire l'effort d'écouter quelque
chose dont ils comprennent pas les
paroles moi c'est aussi le truc que je
trouve vraiment le fun qu'il fait là
il comprend pas les paroles picot il
parle un peu de la parole à mon email à
la forme tu te demandes
ouais comme une espèce de jeu de mots
comme nice kai kai pogné sud ouest mais
je me demande s'il ya quelqu'un qui l'a
traduit pour lui comme je m'en veux un
peu je pense mais qui parle français
donc j'ai pas trop compris mais il met
la gugga comme il y avait pas la
sensibilité au texte avec la musique des
poèmes et sa part est là la critique
comme tel
ils étaient majoritairement positifs
est-ce que tu étais en accord avec ce
que c'est ce que j'aime de lui en fait
c'est qui ça prémices et c'est juste mon
avis fait qu'il est il n'y a pas la
prétention de faire de dire j'ai raison
à ces sociétés c'est comme lui moi je
pense tpiy comme il ya une demi tonne
préférés dont je suis fier qu'il ya pas
tant aimés puis je trouve ce haute parce
que c'est pas juste quelqu'un qui comme
gratuitement comme si la mer c'est lui
ça y'a moins parler c'est bien correct
c'est moi que ça ça m'enlève faut que je
les aime beaucoup puis je viens à 7,9
puis je trouve que c'est une très très
bonne chanson pour moi c'est parce que
j'ai fait puisque je connais mes
capacités
donc je trouve ça le fun de pouvoir que
être content d'un avis moins positifs
sur une tonne t on y est j'écoute
beaucoup plus ouverte à ce que quelqu'un
qui a pas que je sais qu'il ya pas de
culture musicale qui complique comprends
pas ce que j'essaie de faire qui s'est
pas penché sur la question qui a pas de
référent qui aimeraient passer ce serait
comme à montady c'est moi il ya plein
d'albums cd des super gros album que je
tripoli puis ça je n'aime pas dire que
c'est pas bon fait que petit screen -
c'est ben queen c'est que c'est bon le
succès est reconnu mondialement comme
étant bon là je n'aime pas ce seuil et
moi j'adore gentle giant ça dérange pas
qu'il faut c'est pas un mode ces
temps-ci ml preuve non ce poste
non non je pense trois mode en ce moment
tu prends pour savoir venez je sais pas
mais
ouais mais c'est cool parce qu on est
c'est comme aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression qu'on est toutes les uns
contre les autres c'est comme la norme
c'est il faut que toi ton opinion si
l'on n'est pas d'accord faut qu'on soit
contre cécile n'ai pas beaucoup de 2
comme j'entends je suis pas d'accord ces
corps et il n'y a pas beaucoup de sens
on voit rarement ceux qui souvent quand
c'était pas d'accord avec quelqu'un sur
un point c'est comme et des dents de
scie des genres tout le monde a besoin
vraiment de plus de cela mais deux nids
raccourcis sont tellement violent puis
sa langue allemande écoute puis de
l'empathie pigeon juste d' écoute on
partirait pas là dessus après pendant
longtemps mais je pense qu'on a manqué
mettons les réseaux sociaux de mètres de
leur nature fait qu on se pose face à
face et on argumente en pis on t il pas
de dialogue le sujet sont en scandant
opposition plus en plus pipi ap l'inde
affront qui aurait jamais lieu si on
était face à face dans le temps la
personne soient ses intentions il la
personne un peu comme dans même alors
qu'à l'écrit souvent la personne et à
l'art de manger moins et est juste comme
comme ça j'ai vu ce sera le mot de la
fin vous j'ai vu le commentaire le plus
absurde que j'ai vu toute ma vie qui
sait que c'est un groupe qui s'appelle
les accros du cosco qui sait
c'est du monde qui vont co scopique qui
se partage qui dédie au genre voici à
saint-bruno il ya des défauts sur les
bobs cela c'est pas une page satirique
non c'est énormément ces deux mondes qui
trippent cosco quand leur carte qui fera
élire un bon deal sur les lieux le jeune
fille a fait jessains à un monde c'est
des haricots noirs orthez plat dit à
l'ap l'a fait à la reconnaît pas les
arts tournoi s'est passé quoi tient
c'est quoi ce qu'est ce que je fais avec
ce pilote
le premier commentaire c'est madame qui
dit en baisse assez même pas c'est quoi
leur comptoir qui est de folles je vois
ce
le but en bas c'est juste du monde qui
répondent à damas damas faisant madame
vous avez aucun sens
nous avons un primo levi seule défaite
les réseaux sociaux le sais ce que ça
fait les gens non les gens répondaient à
m'adapter la manade il ya plein de monde
qui disent assez des haricots noirs on
peut vous en servir du chili ou avertis
que je cède ma table les gens
répondaient à cette madame madame
problème comment vous vivez que vous
insulter gratuitement quelqu'un qui
demande c'est quoi l'amour édifiant à
sauvian sa vie entre que la
confrontation non mais pas s'avancer
compte des risques et merci à minima
puis puis se sentent encouragés tout le
monde écoute et on y est